(techno music)
- [Leon] Jai alai is a dance.
- [Benny] This is a game of finesse.
It's fast, the balls go between
150 and 170 miles per hour.
- [Narrator] For the better
part of the 20th century,
jai alai was the sport in Miami.
You went to see it and to be seen.
Yet today, the sport is barely hanging on.
So, what happened?
(soft music)
- Jai alai's a sport that was very famous
back in the ’40s, ’50s,
and it comes from Europe, Spain, France.
In 1924, it arrived in Miami.
- [News Anchor] Jai alai, one
of the oldest of all games,
is taking winter residents
of Miami by storm.
- [Narrator] It's been dubbed
the world’s fastest game.
You may have vague memories of seeing it
in a Dos Equis commercial,
or in the opening scene of “Miami Vice.”
- [Benny] It was an exciting sport,
and we used to get a lot of celebrities
that would come out and
wanna be a part of it,
and wanna be seen at jai alai.
- [Narrator] That's Benny Bueno.
He's one of the most decorated American
jai alai players of all time.
He's currently the player
manager at Dania Casino.
- It was a combination of the nightlife,
and getting dressed up
and having a place to go.
The largest crowd that
ever visited Miami Jai Alai
was 15,000 people.
The arena held probably about 12,000.
It's just something that's
visually stimulating
for someone that's never seen it.
It's addicting in a sense.
- I've been playing jai alai for 28 years.
I got to experience a good
five years of 7,000-8,000 people
in the fronton.
It was so loud, you couldn't
really hear your partners.
And it was just awesome to
play in front of a huge crowd.
- [Narrator] Now, the inevitable question:
How did we go from crowds of 10,000 plus
to a scattered 100 on a good day?
- I believe it was in the mid-thirties,
that gambling was legalized on jai alai.
The wagering on jai alai
has always been a blessing
and a curse—in the
sense where the wagering
is what has kept it alive for so long,
but it has kind of taken away
a little bit of the sport,
the athleticism, the game itself.
Over the years, the focus has changed.
It's no longer a jai alai arena,
it is a casino, with a jai alai
arena, with a poker room.
And the focus is mainly on the property
rather just the sport of jai alai.
- [Narrator] But that wasn't
the sports only problem.
In 1981, then owner of World
Jai Alai, Roger Wheeler,
was assassinated.
His murder is associated
with Whitey Bulger
and the Winter Hill Gang.
And the sport became inexorably
tied to organized crime
in the public’s mind.
Then, in 1988, there was a player strike
that lasted three years.
- It all was the perfect
storm, where it started
to take some of our clientele away.
I don't want it to be on my watch
that jai alai goes away or fails.
It's a lot of fun, and
it's something that I did
for 25 years, so I can't just walk away.
- Looking out at the crowd
and seeing less people
doesn't deter my work ethic.
- Go right, go right.
- I'm gonna play the same
level and prepare myself,
whether its 1,000 people or ...
200 people.
Once the balls in the air, you gotta move.
Playing a sport at that
speed every day, you know, is awesome.
I still have the love and
the passion for the game.